what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and today I'm going to be
discussing the end of attack on Titan
and the new Titans that will be popping
up in the fourth season
attack on Titan what's one of the first
anime we covered on the channel and it's
crazy to think that the final season is
almost here if you enjoy seeing attack
on Titan videos on this channel and want
to keep them coming the best thing to do
is smash that like button and share this
video if you haven't be sure to
subscribe this is crucial
hit that notification bell or you will
miss future attack on Titan videos keep
in mind we have a huge attack on Titan
playlist you can check out where we
discuss all nine Titans the Ackerman's
the complete history of attack on Titan
and so much more link to that is in the
description there will be manga spoilers
in this video now without further ado
let's jump into the final season so in
this video since we got the trailer of
the final season I want to go over it as
someone who is caught up with the manga
give my thoughts about it and discuss
what's actually happening in these
scenes for those who want to know or
just want to refresher we start the
trailer with Falco looking at a bird
flying across the air this is happening
on the continent rather than on the
isolated island where most of the attack
on titans story has taken place so far
birds and especially big birds like
Eagles are associated with freedom a
recurring theme in attack on Titan where
the attack Titans whole purpose seems to
be to keep moving forward towards
freedom the world of attack on Titan
feels like a very claustrophobic one
people start out trapped in walls
surrounded by Titans
and then when they finally got to see
last season and they're supposed to be
able to appreciate their freedom they
can't because now they know they're
surrounded beyond the sea by a world of
enemies it seems like every time the old
enemy is defeated a new one pops up that
definitely seems to be the case from the
perspective of our main characters Eren
Mikasa Armin and the rest the next
season will probably start out from the
Marlin perspective remembered our Reiner
Zeek Jaeger and the other Titan shifters
that invaded the island are actually
Marlon Warriors biologically they are LD
UNS like the majority of the island the
Marlins used them because only LD ins
can use the power of the Titans
so falco is one of these up-and-coming
Marlon Warriors up LD inherit
you can tell he's LD and by the armband
he's forced to wear on his left arm
clearly he too is reaching out for the
bird reaching out for freedom he wants
to escape and like Aaron this enemy on
the marlon side also feels trapped this
is going to be a major theme in the
upcoming season showing how both sides
are human both sides are fighting for
their loved ones and both sides are
fighting for freedom and each side
thinks that they can't be free until
they defeat the other but the question
remains when will it ever end can it
ever end we saw in previous seasons that
even among the LD ins on the island
there was inner conflict so will
defeating the Marlins lead to peace or
will a new internal threat just pop up
again these aren't easy questions but
they're questions that attack on Titan
forces us to think about as the trailer
goes on we see that Falco is on a
battlefield where even without the
island LD ins a war is raging between a
walled city and the Marlin invaders it's
clearly getting much more complicated
since the days when Humanity was
supposed to be the good guy and Titans
were supposed to be the bad guys and I
know some people don't like the shift
and focus from Titans being the main
enemy but I personally thought the Bruce
Willis level twist in the basement was
amazing and arguably the best twist that
I've seen in all of anime we're then
told that time draws near
until the next warriors chosen to
inherit the armored Titan riders Titan
we're showing the kids that are up for
the running who include riders own
little cousin Gabby one of the most
hated characters in attack on Titan but
she behaves exactly like Aaron did when
he was a kid
no one has yet to inherit riders Titan
from him in the manga but Reiner
definitely never wanted Gabby to have it
while she is pretty brainwashed in the
beginning and thinks it would be a good
thing Reiner has been disillusioned
after everything he experienced he knows
the horrible fate that awaits warriors
including Ymir's curse which means that
people can't live longer than 13 years
will shift their powers if you look at
Gabby and this trailer her eyes are
bright and hopeful she really thinks at
this point that by being the best
moorland warrior she could be she could
make a better world for herself her
family and the other non Island Aldean's
we see Zeke and Reiner post time skip
riders 21 years old and Zeke is 29 years
old and Ymir's curse is getting closer
and closer
each passing day attack on titan has
never really felt like a shounen to me
which tends to be primarily directed
towards teenage dudes it's always felt a
lot darker crueler and more gruesome and
with the time-skip it really feels like
we are much more insane and territory
which are manga primarily directed
towards dudes in their 20s to 50s
definitely don't expect Eren to talk
about the power of friendship we see
Porco using the JA Titan that yamir had
to destroy railways the theme of
advancing technology and where that
leaves the LD and is very much present
in this final-season
it is only a matter of time until
technology surpasses the power of titans
think of planes that can drop bombs that
can wipe out humanity on the island in
one shot Titans are still very much an
important factor in this season but the
advancing technology adds even more
urgency and even greater feelings of
entrapment
after all if technology renders titan
power obsolete why would Marlins and
others want to keep these people they
view as monsters alive this version of
the jaw Titan has a hardened face and is
arguably more powerful than Ymir's
version as we'll figure out it's very
powerful in its own way it's claws and
jaws can even cut through the crystal
material that Titan users like Annie can
use to surround their human bodies we
haven't seen any other Titan be capable
of scratching that material so that
really is insane
not to mention that jata is supposed to
have speed and to be the swiftest Titan
- I'm not going to go into crazy detail
about the Titans I'll just highlight
some key points about them in this video
if you want a more detailed breakdown
you can check out my all nine times on
their powers explained video or find the
video about the specific Titan that you
want to learn more about links in the
description it's great to finally see
this all animated because it really
gives a better sense of the size of the
Titans the car Titan is seen and people
look like bugs around it we also get a
good look of its armor and how soldiers
are shooting guns from atop its back
think back how crazy this would have
seemed during the first season we now
have what appeared to be machine guns
being shot from a cooperating Titans
back that's wearing real armor we're
told there's a new world and we catch
glimpses of the continent and the Marlin
warriors and candidates heading to the
Libero internment zone where aggression
was from the
the barrio originates from the Latin
word liebe air which I have no idea if I
said it right but the important thing is
it means free so again we have the idea
of freedom being brought up it is a
deeply ironic name in this case since
this so named city of freedom has an
internment zone in it and the audience
are treated as anything but free we see
poor code the user of the jaw tighten
and peak the female user of the car type
another wife who candidate for the
attack on Titan fandom she actually
needs help to walk on two legs after
being the car Titan for long enough the
car Titan is known for its endurance and
the user can maintain their Titan form
for way longer than any other Titan and
as we all know it can also carry things
like a kart peak is also intelligent
there's a lot to her character and
plenty to like we see what looks like
Gabi and Falco clashing they are both
trying to inherit the armored Titan but
for different reasons
Gabi actually wants it while falco even
though he's young too is not as
brainwashed he wants it so that Gabi
doesn't have to become a Titan he wants
to save her from that faith so it's
quite the love story between them
it's interesting how it's set up that
they are competing but both actually are
seeking what they think is in the best
interest for Gabi a baseball flash is on
screen which a lot of people would
probably be surprised by this is a
reference to Zeke's mentor and the
previous user of the beast Titan they
used to play cash together passing the
ball back and forth in a way Zeke's
mentor also passed on his philosophy to
Zeke along with his beast Titan powers I
talked about this side of the story in
detail in my Zeke's twisted philosophy
explained video link in the description
but long story short I completely
disagree with Zeke's philosophy but his
backstory does a great job of helping
you understand how he came to adopt it
the idea of saving the world is
mentioned and that's another thing
that's constantly popping up an attack
on Titan everyone is trying to save the
world in their own way and ironically
those clash and philosophies are what
keep the world at war and keep it from
actually being saved
we have Reiner thinking about dying
before Ymir's curse even kicks in he
takes a rifle and makes it seem like
he's gonna shoot it and we even hear
what
sounds like it could be a gunshot of
course manga readers no he doesn't do it
but riders mental health or lack thereof
is definitely something that keeps
coming up up to this season his
personality split because of the amount
of trauma guilt and PTSD he was dealing
with although he's working against Aaron
you can't help but empathize with Reiner
after you learned everything about him
in his backstory like most others he's
trying to do the best he can and he's
not under the illusion that he's a good
guy or that his enemies are the bad guys
he hates himself but he just didn't see
another way just as the Islanders fought
for their own reiner and the other
warriors are fighting for their own
families who are pretty much hostages of
the Marlins few anime depict the
complexities of war as well as attack on
Titan in my view and this is gonna be
especially the case with this last
season then we see eren's Titan mr lay
on the continent
that's when Aaron just heads there by
himself infiltrates them and starts to
attack on his own getting to them before
they could get to him kind of thing the
last of the nine Titans to be revealed
fights it it's in the possession of the
Tiber family and its powers are actually
pretty epic it's called the Warhammer
Titan and it can form weapons and these
weapons can take the form of what looks
like earthbending - it can create a
Warhammer and arrow launcher spikes from
the ground big or small a sword and so
on
what's more the user can chill in an an
es crystal in the ground while operating
this Titan by means of a cord connected
to its leg this means that this Titan
shifters pretty much unbeatable without
the jaw Titan who can actually break
through that hard crystal this fight is
definitely gonna be one of the
highlights of the final season we then
see that the survey Corps have come to
back up Aaron even though they didn't
want to invade at all since Aaron has
the attack Titan in founding Titan power
he is the single most important chess
piece on the board and so if he decides
to do something stupid he can make the
survey Corps support him against their
wealth because they just can't lose him
for this reason we see a lot of Aaron
acting unilaterally aka on his own not
really caring if others understand what
his true plan is we also see grown
Mikasa which is cool because up for ever
best girl
attack on titan you can definitely tell
how much older she looks to like Harry
Potter it feels like the maturity of the
story is aging with the characters as
well we're told that the truth will be
questioned another common theme an
attack on Titan what is the truth who
gets to decide what the truth was
it seems like history has been decided
by the victors at this point and we'll
see if Aaron and the others managed to
somehow break the cycle of the seat
we're shown Armin who was about to use
the explosion ability of his colossal
Titan something we'll get to see in the
new season Titan battles are emphasized
in this trailer and that will be an epic
part of the final season although there
will also be plenty of politics as well
we even see Levi's slicing up Titans
something that will happen later on when
he's taken care of Zeek and believe it
or not Zeek will actually get the better
of him in that one although in general
Levi has tended to Rex Zeek in conflict
the voice of the Tiber in the trailer
says that Eren Yeager stole the founding
Titan and positions him in the role of
villain Eren Jaeger is the one keeping
the world from peace according to Tiber
and this view of Eren being the final
villain of the series is also gonna be
emphasized in this season Aaron starts
acting on his own he antagonizes Mikasa
and Armin and his actions lead to many
people's deaths currently in the manga
our main characters aside from Eren are
trying to figure out how to stop Eren
from destroying the world and he
supposedly wants to destroy the world so
that it will finally stop targeting the
ldiots on the island I don't think Aaron
actually plans to destroy the world I've
been thinking for a long time that he's
going to take the hate of the world on
himself Lelouch from Code Geass style
and then sacrificed his own life in
order to defuse the hate to an extent
after all could the world want to kill
the island dwellers if they stopped a
big bad Eren from killing them and all
their loved ones in theory that could
create a basis on which to try to create
a more peaceful world however will we
actually see Aaron die and will such a
plan work in the attack on Titan world
where a new conflict always seems to pop
up no matter what now remains to be seen
all I know is that I'm extremely excited
to see how this will all wrap up let me
know what you think including your
craziest theories for the ending because
with a series like attack on
titin I don't think anything would
surprise me at this point the only other
thing in the trailer that especially
stands out to me is the image of yamir
the founder we will be learning more
about her her history and will even see
her as a player in the attack on titans
story after thousands of years which is
very exciting we also see shots of the
final battle which is taking place on
the island too so we'll definitely be
finishing up everything this season even
though the manga hasn't even ended yet
this trailer is practically caught up to
the manga we're told in the trailer that
this will be the last attack and that
brings us back to the name attack on
Titan and the idea that perhaps
sometimes doing something is the way to
bring about change rather than passively
waiting and hoping for change to come
about on its own whatever happens
Aaron was someone who refused to sit by
and do nothing while other people
decided his fate and the fate of his
loved ones whether right or wrong he did
something and soon enough we'll see how
that works out for him and that is it
for this video where I discussed the
trailer a bit and talked about the end
of attack on Titan one of my favorite
manga ever it's been a crazy ride over
the years and it's probably gonna get
even crazier before it's over if you
want to see more attacks on Titan videos
on this channel the best you can do is
Warhammer smash that like button and
share this video if you haven't be sure
to subscribe but this is crucial ring
that notification bell or you will miss
future attack on Titan videos leave
suggestions for what type of topics you
still want me to cover in the comments
and be sure to check out our Titanic
playlist of attack on Titan videos link
in the description lastly the YouTube ad
rates have significantly dropped
recently so the help and support we're
getting from our anime opera patrons is
now more important than ever a very
special thank you goes out to our
patrons over on patreon who help us
survive these YouTube issues and who
helped make videos like this one
possible first and foremost I want to
thank the legend acknowledged by Lord
Twigg o himself
Efrain a and the one tier patrons the
ones who stand atop all clans Steven and
Rana
Aloha autumn dough world stealers
acquire respect potato feh
Jonathan king deci d brandon a vials
Papa Smurf the school bus emperor otaku
and Ritchie Martinez and our pro hero
tier patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson King's
elders Anatoly kozloski
angel Cruz I Sparky 65 cricket XP Ted no
Ted Joel Stanton Mary gucci alicia actor
animal 69 jessica calif on he no commie
and water bunny park so dr 12 worth
'when day or tian fong mitch loves anime
cynical Kraken and JCC wakka thank you
all so much
if you enjoy our work you get support
more read by going over to patreon calm
and may uproar and becoming a patriot
today for as little as $1 if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you'll even get access to
a private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course dank
memes so check out Pete calm and May out
for a link in the description if you're
interested you can also now join the
youtube channel and support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way to
support us you can get the same great
benefits thanks again and until next
time see us bass cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]